let me ask you this a question from
Jordan Peterson that he asked uh when I
told him that I'm speaking with you
given everything you've said when does
the left go too far
I suppose he's referring to
cultural issues
identity politics
well you know
Jordan trying to get me to bad mouth the
laugh the whole time I was in I I really
enjoyed my my uh my talk with him yeah
but he seemed to have that agenda where
he wanted me to you know say bad things
about the left and I just don't you know
that's not what my campaign is about I
want to do the opposite
oh I'm not going to bad mouth laugh they
try you know I was on a show this week
with David remnick from the New Yorker
and he tried to get me to bad mouth
Donald Trump and you know and Alex Jones
and a lot of other people just and and
baiting me to do it
and of course there's a lot of bad
things I could say about all those
people but it doesn't you know I'm
trying to find
I'm trying to find values that hold us
together and we can share in common
rather than to focus constantly on these
disputes and these issues that drive us
apart so me sitting here bad-mouthing
the left or bad mouthing the right is
not going to advance the ball I I really
want to figure out ways that you know
what do these groups hold in common that
we can all
you know have a shared vision of what we
want this country to look like well
that's music to my ears